[Music]
the war in ukraine shows it is almost
impossible to live a normal life when
fighting is going all around you think
about that for just a second more than
four million people have fled from the
country since russia invaded five weeks
ago but ninety percent
ninety percent of the country's
population has stayed trying to do their
work and support their families deborah
pat is in the capitol keefe she spoke to
some of the people who have found a way
to function in the chaos all around them
when your home is being shelled and your
town besieged you run as far away as you
can people have fled the worst of the
war to the relative safety of cave and
surrounding towns
in bravery katja found shelter in this
kindergarten with her four children
after her home burnt down now she shares
a classroom with over 25 other people
are you worried that the russians could
come here
of course we're worried about it she
says
nowhere is completely safe in the
capital where air sirens and distant
shelling have become the soundtrack of
daily life the streets have emptied out
this is the heart of the city it used to
be a vibrant center now it's a fortified
military zone
before the wall victor was an
electrician he last picked up a gun
during his mandatory conscription 12
years ago
at the beginning i was astounded at
what's happening he said then i realized
it's not a joke it's actually a
patriotic wall
incredibly grocery stores are still open
and when there is no physical comfort to
be found
there is always the spiritual
prayers for peace have never been more
urgent
[Music]
in underground bars turned bunkers young
volunteers relax and tell war stories
outside others mix cocktails the molotov
kind instead of partying the night away
they also provide food and shelter for
exhausted fighters
max palienko walks to work every morning
to open up his basement flower shop
instead of a gun he's holding out a hand
of friendship selling flowers and hope
it's my job
brilliant smile and happiness
i'm staying in the cave
katja and her kids are here to stay too
they have nowhere else to go
are you scared
we are she says are you scared of the
alarms and when these big bangs
no
lives turned upside down by war
for cbs morning's debra patter cave
ukraine
life turned upside down but carries on